hey guys how's it going so today i want
to walk you through the architectural
design process from start to finish and
you can get a little sense of how we
work with other professionals in the
process if you're new here my name is
dany and i am an architect in beautiful
vancouver bc on this channel we talk
about architecture and design as well as
some tools and strategies that can help
us have more meaningful and fulfilling
careers in architecture this video is
sponsored by autodesk to get started
with your subscription click on the link
in the description
so this was a project we did for a net
zero competition called race to zero and
our team actually won first place in the
multi-family housing category it was a
multi-disciplinary team with myself and
two architecture students a building
science team and the developer who had
already purchased the site every client
is going to come to you with different
project goals it can be a simple
functional goal or maybe to maximize
views or an energy target or improving
the existing conditions whatever it is
it's very important to understand this
early on and let this guide the process
especially for sustainability targets
whether it's lead or net zero or passive
house or just like future proofing the
building
these will have a pretty big impact on
the building
so for projects like this it's very
important to get the consultants
involved earlier on in the process for a
integrated design process
before starting any design we need to
analyze the site to set up the
constraints that our design is going to
respond to so you're going to be looking
at all the existing conditions like the
neighboring buildings the topography
as well as potential future conditions
and you also want to take a look at the
zoning regulations and the maximum
buildable area or setbacks the fsr
and actually if you want a detailed
breakdown of how we develop a massing
model from the zoning requirements check
out the video right here
one of the most challenging and
contentious things about building on
urban sites is
the parking most cities have minimum
parking requirements because they don't
want their streets to be littered with
cars
but parking is expensive and it takes up
a lot of space
and in this construction climate it can
sometimes make or break a project
so you just want to check to see if
there's any parking relaxations for your
site which is you know typically
dependent on your site's proximity to
transit or other amenities as soon as i
have the site info i started modeling
things in revit pretty early on just to
understand the relationship to the site
and develop some rough massing options
for the building
these massing models now become the
basis for your site strategy which you
develop through a process called
diagramming in these early schematic
stages we iterate through a bunch of
different diagrams to help us have a
more high level discussion on the
direction of our design strategy without
going too much into detail this process
can help you figure out the relationship
between your building and the site or
the building circulation or the
building's organizational strategy
so through the process of diagramming
you'll probably flush out a lot of the
bad ideas and select a few ones that you
or your team likes you can definitely
have your favorites but you still want
to try to present all of the viable
options to the client and i think the
client always appreciates being a part
of the decision making process
as you present these massing options you
always want to back it up with numbers
whether it's a developer or a family
wanting to build their first home
if the math doesn't work out chances are
the project isn't going to go through so
you want to be really clear on how much
area you're providing with each option
one of the great things about using a
bim modeling software like revit is that
you can do these massing studies and the
model is going to give you a pretty
accurate breakdown of the areas without
you actually having to calculate it
manually the client's going to be
running their own numbers to make the
project make sense financially but you
are responsible for showing them the
areas and the quantity and the quality
of the spaces that you're creating
there's usually a bit of back and forth
with the client at the stage especially
if the client's a developer they're
going to want to maximize the profits on
this building meaning they're going to
want to maximize on the number of units
in most cases so
you need to remind them of the project's
goals from time to time in this case for
this project the most efficient unit
layout would have been to have units on
the south end and on the north end
but one of the main goals for the
project was to reach net zero or passive
health standard and the building science
team identified pretty early on that if
we wanted to aim for that target we
would need to use passive heating and
cooling strategies
meaning
we need to orient the building north
south this way every unit can take
advantage of the solar gain from the
south side with passive ventilation
through the building so there was quite
a lot of back and forth during this
process because the premium you can
charge for being a net zero building is
not quite enough to make up for an
entire unit that's why these types of
discussions on the project's goals are
really important to have early on
once you figure out the general
direction of the building you start to
fine tune the layout with furniture
blocks or doors or windows i usually
print them out and overlay them with
sketch or i bring the base drawings into
procreate and start sketching directly
on there once i got the layout on sketch
i bring it back into revit and the
process usually goes back and forth
between manual and digital you might
have guessed by now drafting and 3d
modeling is a pretty integral part of my
design process right from the beginning
i've always used autodesk products like
autocad and revit but just this past
year thanks to some of the
collaborations that we've been doing
i've been learning a lot more about the
other creative industries that autodesk
is involved in they're not just leaders
in the architecture or construction
industries but also in manufacturing
media entertainment and they have this
goal of empowering innovation everywhere
to solve challenges of all scales if you
want to learn more about some of the
innovative projects they're part of
i'm going to leave the link to my visit
to the autodesk gallery in san francisco
right here revit is a building
information modeling software with the
ability to generate things like area
calculations or windows schedules or
door schedules directly from the model
it automates a lot of the things that
historically architects would have had
to do manually i personally think in
order for architecture to move into the
future
we need to automate more and more things
so that we can focus on the important
things like designing and working with
clients honestly i can't imagine revit
not being a part of my workflow if
you're a student they have financing
options meaning with a valid education
email you can use the product for free
they also have tons of free tutorials
and resources to help you get started to
get started with your subscription click
on the link in the description
as architects we try to create order
and that goes for elevations as well for
this project once again because we did
have this net zero target the building
science team gave us the maximum area of
windows that we could have on both
facades we also had requirements for
overhangs with a fairly strict depth so
working within these two constraints you
know as well as the interior functions
you start to develop the elevation trace
is probably the best tool for developing
rough ideas because no idea is too
precious and you can layer ideas one on
top of another you can start to develop
the elevation by deciding what areas to
highlight use proportions or the golden
section to break up the facade
just like you did with the plans you
start diagrammatically and then you
start to build in details or ideas for
materials once i've got the idea i bring
it back into revit to get a better sense
of how it works in 3d and once i model
it in 3d i do another printout of these
different views and i just keep
developing more and more iterations
either on paper or on my ipad and it's a
workflow that seems to work for me
[Applause]
you know that saying a picture is worth
a thousand words
renderings are a very important part of
the process because no matter how good
of an explanation you have for your
project
if you can't inspire them about how this
could be
they're not going to shell out millions
of dollars to build this thing
the rendering is the thing that sells
the project to the client or the city or
the stakeholders so we typically develop
multiple renderings throughout the
lifespan of the project we do it during
schematic design and as we develop the
design and everyone gets to have
feedback on the design like the client
or the city or the community and through
this you refine and develop the design
even more now this covers the
architectural design process in very
very broad strokes and i haven't even
touched on how your consultants could
impact the design if you're wondering
about how we actually work with
consultants and the role of each of the
major engineers i have a video on that
i'll leave it right here and if you're
curious about how to develop a concept
for a real project i'll leave the video
right here remember to like this video
if you found it helpful subscribe if
you're not already a subscriber and hit
the bell if you want to be notified as
soon as i release a new video i also
have a newsletter and a discord server
i'll leave the links to both in the
description
and with that i'll see you guys in the
next video
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you